es ist ein szenario das seltsam
unwirklich wirkt altena im kreis
ahrweiler einer der ersten orte den die
flutwelle traf und sie traf alte narben
besonders schlimm
daniel robbe berichtet uns wie er das
erlebt hat er ist reporter bei einer
lokalzeitung und hat fotos gemacht sind
das protokoll einer tragödie
die bisher im kreis ahrweiler 132
todesopfer zählt und die die menschen
erschreckend unvorbereitet traf
das wusste ja keiner das ist so ist weil
sonst werden die 500 500 häuser sind weg
700 sind beschädigt
das große aufräumen hat gerade erst
begonnen es wird jahre dauern und es
wird geld kosten und mit dem schlamm
kommen für daniel wrobel auch immer mehr
fragen auf wir haben jetzt hier eine
regionen trümmern ja und es ist ja auch
irgendwie eine frage der
schadensregulierung irgendeiner muss
dafür gerade stehen und uns da bei dem
aufbau aktiv helfen und das geht auch
mit geld und am idealsten dass derjenige
der uns da hat hängen lassen
wer hat die menschen hier hängen
gelassen die zuständigen
katastrophenschützer weisen jede
verantwortung von sich
gewusst hat jeder gast etwas auf uns
zukommt sagt nrw-innenminister herbert
reul malu dreyer ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland pfalz sagt die kreise und die
gemeinden bekommen immer sofort wenn
sich die pegelstände erhöhen nachrichten
und warnhinweise und armin schuster von
der zuständigen bundesbehörde unsere
waren infrastruktur hat geklappt im bund
aber wie kam es dann zu so vielen toten
rüdiger fuhrmann es bürgermeister von
altena und er ist feuerwehrmann als das
wasser hier steht die steigt verfolgt er
die vorhersagen für die pegelstände auf
dem handy sie haben doch mit der mit der
app geguckt main pegel so gut es ging
hammer das gemacht haben war dass ich
habe mal bis circa 17 17 30
noch am vormittag prognostiziert das
hochwasserzentrum rheinland pfalz für
die nacht einen höchststand der von etwa
3 meter fünfzig erst am nachmittag wird
die prognose plötzlich angehoben auf
über 5 meter es sind jetzt nur noch
wenige stunden bis die katastrophe ihren
lauf nimmt
also wir haben werden mittags
tatsächlich in der feuerwehr auch schon
zusammengesetzt und gesagt soll man
meist fünf täter soll das wasser
herkommt
wenn wir uns jetzt nur auf diese
hochwasservorhersage verlassen hätten
hätten hätten wir vielleicht auch anders
reagieren müssen
das mag sein das hätte die schädigungen
mit sicherheit ja nicht verhindert aber
wir hätten vielleicht noch menschenleben
retten können das aber wir haben es
wirklich in dieser form auch nicht
erwartet es gab sicherlich
entscheidungsschwäche in der politik das
heißt auf niederer ebene hat sich der
ein oder andere bürgermeister oder auch
die landrätin vielleicht nicht getraut
bei vergleichsweise mehrdeutigen
meldungen sofort alarm auszulösen und zu
evakuieren
das mag ein fehler gewesen sein aber die
warnmeldung muss auch als warnmeldung
verpackt werden damit sie von den
politikern auch als solche wahrgenommen
denn das scheint hier nicht der fall
gewesen zu sein
um 20 uhr 45 meter letztes mal der pegel
gemessen unglaubliche fünf meter 75 dann
fällt das messgerät aus als am abend in
bad neuenahr die pegelstände steigen ist
rheinland-pfalz innenminister persönlich
vor ort dann fährt er nach hause
sie haben gesagt sie waren bis 19 uhr 30
beim krisenstab
und es war eine derartige lage nicht
absehbar gleichzeitig hat auch ihr
eigenes die eigene hochwassermeldedienst
seit nachmittags von pegelständen von 5
bis sogar siebenmeter gewarnt wie kann
das sein
also die situation die ich mir
angeschaut war ob vorbereitungen für die
warnmeldungen nach meiner einschätzung
getroffen waren sind die einheiten
draußen werden die
hochwasserschutzmaßnahmen hochgefahren
am abend korrigierte das land rheinland
pfalz seine prognose noch einmal
erheblich nach oben auf rund sieben
meter anwohnern zufolge wird das wasser
am ende auf über 10 meter steigen
das heißt aber die behörden vor ort die
feuerwehrleute sagen sie die hatten aber
die warnung von pegelständen bis zu
sieben metern
sie wissen dass die warnung auch
verbunden waren mit hinweisen straßen
können überflutet werden bitte nicht im
keller gehen aber es war keine situation
die beschrieben hat das was wir am
schluss heute wissen siebenmeter ich
kenne die meldung nicht auf die sie sich
beziehen meine meldungen haben zu dem
zeitpunkt noch dem stand gehalten was
die kreisverwaltung in der vorbereitung
hatten
hier beobachten sie die lage rund um die
uhr weltweit im bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
in bonn aktiv geworden ist die behörde
mit ihren 400 mitarbeitern aber nicht
der grund die betroffenen bundesländer
hätten keine hilfe angefordert
letzten endes kann das bbk auch selbst
dienstleistungen an die kreise und
kreisfreien städte anbieten und wir
haben bei dieser flutkatastrophe die
absurde situation dass diese katastrophe
letztlich vor der tür des bbk gespielt
hat
in berlin muss der bbk chef gestern vor
dem innenausschuss des bundestags rede
und antwort stehen
mindestens 179 menschen sind in der flut
gestorben die verantwortung wird seit
tagen zwischen bund und ländern hin und
her geschoben
ich muss ihnen aber ohne irgendjemanden
dieser opfer jetzt zu verhöhnen doch
sagen können dass das was ich
verantworte nämlich dass die wahren
infrastruktur die wir sieben stunden 7
tage 24 stunden das ganze jahr über zur
verfügung stellen müssen für die länder
und kommunen dass die funktioniert hat
herzstück dieser infrastruktur ist die
katastrophen waren app nina sie soll die
bevölkerung über akute gefahren
informieren
doch im besonders schwer getroffenen
kreis ahrweiler wurde keine einzige
warnung über die nidda app versandt nina
hat in jedem fall gewarnt
indem es beauftragt wurde
da wo nina nicht angesprochen wurde kann
es auch nicht warnen
wir dürfen ja im katastrophenfall nicht
selbst waren
ich bin schon sehr erstaunt wie man sich
jetzt auch so technische analysen
zurückzieht nur um zu unterstreichen
dass man selbst keine verantwortung für
das trägt was da vorgefallen ist im
konkreten geht es doch darum dass man
feststellen muss menschen sind nicht
gewarnt worden und menschen die
vielleicht hätten eine warnung absetzen
sollen konnten es selber nicht weil
ihnen selbst das dach weggeflogen ist
oder sie selbst sich vor fluten in
sicherheit bringen mussten das hotel zur
post stand direkt am fluss günter lang
war hier im restaurant mit 80 gästen
beim abendessen als das wasser immer
schneller immer höher stieg er konnte
alle in sicherheit bringen
zum glück konnte günter lang sich selbst
helfen
erstens ist keiner das heißt die
information dass er so hoch war eben
kann dabei in die hinein
auch bei der feuerwehr nicht haben ihre
wagen selbst mit waren bahnhof geparkt
wie wir unsere gäste auch die fahrzeuge
sind alle schwimmen gegangen
die feuerwehren jetzt wusste das auch
nicht dass es so schlimm hre musste
keiner oder hat man uns nicht gesagt
aber so aus ganz deutschland kommen
jetzt helfer um auch günter lang und
sein hotel zu unterstützen
seine geschichte ist eine von unzähligen
hier von menschen die in der katastrophe
auf sich alleine gestellt waren die
jetzt aufräumen müssen ohne zu wissen ob
sie die kraft haben werden ihre existenz
hier wieder aufzubauen
[Musik]